deuxième séquence dans la régie finale
première chaîne rue cognacq-jay ce soir
là sur l'antenne dans la série en votre
âme et conscience
la faire scier ski de services notre
charmante speakerine jakin cora il ne
lui avions préparé une petite
plaisanterie
igor barrère à contenus communs vous
savez que pendant la diffusion d'un
programme
les speakerines sont de veille quelque
sorte prête à intervenir en cas
d'incidents techniques et notre but dans
cette petite séquence était justement de
créer un incident technique à l'insu de
jacqueline torra voilà alors donc on a
les trucs et son poste quelque sorte son
récepteur oui c'est bien que le savez
que chaque speakerine à devant une
caméra et un poste de télévision qui lui
permet de contrôler d'une part sa propre
image et d'autre part ce qui se passe
sur l'antenne nous avions réussi avec la
complicité avec de nos amis techniciens
de modifier le récepteur de télévision
quelque sorte le contrôle de l'antenne
et à un moment donné sur ce récepteur
utilisions nous avons interrompu l'image
chacune corps à la vue à rossi au même
moment un ordre du chef de sel nisand
d'intervenir car il y avait une panne
sur le réseau ce qui était faux gardes
tout se passait bien sûr l'antenne mais
pour jacqueline cora il y avait une
panne alors comment s'en sortir
les français mais c'était un instrument
de guerre et non d'assassinât
il est curieux que vous ayez dix à mort
et avec ça on aurait pu des molières
charles 10 toute la famille oui mais je
savais que marc était républicain j'ai
dû me servir de cet exemple pour
l'intéressé je ne trouve pas d'autre
explication vous donner notre speakerine
pour l'instant est très décontractée
mais la fausse fans va arriver dans
quelques instants
chacune cora va intervenir et
contrairement à l'habitude
elle va demeurer très très longtemps à
l'image trop longtemps jacqueline on est
en panne sur le réseau actuellement il
ya une coupure entre les buttes chaumont
et ici il faudra faire une danse d'
excuse mais l'émission ne poussez pas
l'émission et intérêts non non c'est pas
en direct
c'est un emprunt est la variante
coupleurs et pessoa dans les buttes
chaumont et élargit finale d'accord
d'accord
alors on va vous faire passer
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs une
coupure de faisceaux entre nos studios
début de chaumont et la régie finale de
cognac jay nous a mis dans l'obligation
d'interrompre pendant quelques instants
les diffusions de la sphère pièce qui
est j'espère que vous voudrez bien ne
pas nous en tenir rigueur et avoir
l'amabilité de bien vouloir patienter
quelques instants d'avant ce merci comme
vous j'attends
vous le voyez j'attends que nous
puissions retrouver les héros de cette
affaire à ces ténébreuses a pondu
en votre âme et conscience que pensez
vous de ce personnage keffieh ce qui est
il un simulateur ou non j'avoue que
personnellement je n'ai pas pu encore
former une opinion
eh bien voyez-vous quelquefois la
technique nous joue des tours
le soyons passion et nous nous
replongeront dans cette ambiance
sa fille parce que c'est elle qui
connaît là et vous visez vous aura
bientôt finir cette panne
eh bien voyez-vous nous ne savons pas si
cette panne se poursuit je crois que oui
parce que j'aperçois que je suis
toujours sur antenne oui bravo mon temps
à ça il faudrait le demander à nos
techniciens
comment ça vous ne le fera pas vous êtes
au courant puisque vous aimez vous voyez
vous je ne suis pas au courant
et souvent les téléspectateurs ne se
rendent pas compte ils se disent
certainement la présentatrice doit
savoir ce qui se passait bien non la
présentatrice est une simple
téléspectatrices et elle attend on
attend des morts au courant puisque
c'est vous qui l'annoncé toujours quand
même parce qu'on vous que vous
connaissez la suite
et non je ne connais pas la suite il
faudra bien la connaître parce qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous de pied ski au
snow un véhicule belge de convives
émerveillé non non je parle de
l'ensemble
olemps sa télévision ça c'est très
facile et s'intéresse tellement
justement on était là avec toulouse ne
connaît quasiment voudrais bien savoir
la suite puis faire la consommation va
finir vous allez prendre patience et
comme je n'ai jamais s'énerver très
intéressant de se dominer un petit peu
puis à l'heure pendant ce temps là on
fait des suppositions son imagination ou
laisse libre cours à toutes les
fantaisies pourquoi pas oui sûrement
enfin vous voyez sur un plan ou voir
pour entendre le retourner là bas
l'ophone seulement qu'est ce que nous
entendons je pense vous demandez sartre
la wii à tout à l'heure actuelle vers la
caméra visionner avant dit oui tout de
suite en entrant au port à nos enfants
non je me suis dit hier j'ai cru que
c'était le pompier égarés oui j'ai connu
le pompier de la maison puis je me suis
dit pompiers vraiment ses proches de
l'uniforme qu'il préfère celui d'agent
de police français je suis les
mitraillent passion c'est une démission
je préfère alors j'espère que nos
téléspectateurs se sont amusés aussi
parce qu'on vit vraiment non non non je
suis à distinguer ce soit au pied
eh bien je suis ici pour moi et bientôt
bientôt et bien c'est une surprise
agréable vous ne pouvez pas